hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to hmm hmm that's played
with the controller that's not a good
sign oh I'm about to die horribly in
horrible ways a boy hello everybody my
name is markiplier and welcome to Manuel
Samuel the game that you guys want me to
play because you want me to get very
angry I saw preview this game and it
seems like the exact type game that's
gonna make me very angry so we're gonna
have a great time playing a manual
Samuel if this is [ __ ] copy I plugged
it in do I got to restart the goddamn oh
we're off to a great start
okay hello welcome to manual Samuel the
game that you guys want me to play
because I'm gonna rage a whole lot I've
already said that but I'm saying again
just in case I don't decide to use that
first in trouble but something tells me
I will bang so from what I can
understand
oh god cough I can't imagine that from
what I understand this is like some sort
of physics based do your own dangle
thing you can't control your goddamn
body sort of deal but it's a story based
game apparently I don't know a lot about
the story or what the story is even
gonna be about but I know it's about a
guy begins in the middle of the 40s
oh and a hopeful young soldier called
Sam oh we're not doing that
our story begins in the middle of last
Tuesday we're a hopeless young
freeloader called Sam is sipping a fancy
cup of coffee with a name nobody can
pronounce okay Sal was born with a
silver spoon in his mouth
oh but not the actual spoon that he has
in his mouth now that is a different
spool of the human drama see here ative
spoon it represents all the wealth and
attention that he has been receiving
from his parents nice and the butler's
oh and their Butler's parents oh you're
a douche
aren't you sir Chili's twice if yes
I can't hear oh this is Sam's girlfriend
also not being heard by Sam she's mad at
Sam for his lack of responsibility
produced by his large
wealth she also mentions the fact that
Sam has forgotten her birthday for the
third year in a row hmm Sam's girlfriend
is upset as with most rich and famous
brats Sam does not pick up on that hmm
instead he decides to lay this gel
things just work out for me baby I can't
just run around and do stuff and end up
with a limp spine Sam's girlfriend does
something she should have done a long
time ago ah oh ow why I don't think
physical violence was warranted
oh geez laying unconscious on the floor
not really his eyes are open others his
strength and makes an effort to get up
oh okay
then he makes another effort to stand up
straight okay I'm ready
Sam is hit in the head so hard he has to
remind himself how to walk Oh No takes a
right step oh he takes a left step good
job Sam you're very good at existing oh
ah oh sorry pardon me
how dare you startle my child an
overprotective mother hurls a cup of
coffee in Sam's face he has to blink
rapidly to regain his vision something
Harold uh oh gee how is our son going to
become a respected politician if he
can't fend for himself I thought he was
gonna become an actor
oh what's the difference uh uh I don't
know but I'll leave your political
satire for something else
I'm still learning how to be human
Mookie
hey I'm not supposed to go that way well
buddy hippity hoppity so I had some
misconceptions about what this game is
and I want to apologize in advance
because it seems a lot more interesting
and fun
we dabba-doo BD hey how you doing
Pompeii's the guy 500 euros barely
covering the coffee just this hip douche
bag Wow Sam decides to hurl another 500
at the guy
not such a douchebag after all oh yay ha
ha's hurling stacks of 500 s left and
right he has no perception of money I
figured may have been the traumatic
brain injury that I had but also because
I'm a rich spoiled brat you want some on
and his whole weekly allowance on
tipping a barista named Tony hey I like
this guy he was hit hard in the head
it's not so bad also why is there a
picture of me in the back behind my rich
parents and my mother with dead eyes
holy feces I'll just start my own coffee
shop once again Sam make someone quit
their job by tipping them too much okay
bye you're welcome
yeah can i still hurl money at the empty
counter hey what am i money okay all
right goodbye then oh but a little bit
of it bibbidi-bobbidi bit there bub baby
taboo let me just let me just slap your
table once or twice okay
how's it good does a good table let me
go look at the feel of that oh that's
nice
hey you want a hundreds did you want 500
I've got
that's a 500 yeah I can slap something
else down on this table in here okay I'm
on my way
how about a half a Badou Herbert a
pepper do can I can I just can I stop
doing the moonwalk for one second and
hurl another $500 bill this door here
nope right Mouse it's it's time spends a
decade making his way out the door which
is pretty good for a guy with a major
concussion yeah okay caused by an
abusive girlfriend waggles outside he
sees his girlfriend on the other side of
the road uh pulls in Joe Jamie Jim
Dennison Ward's his soon-to-be ex
girlfriend you don't know that I mean I
probably should considering she whacked
me upside the head with a bottle and the
Super's went a septic tank truck
approaches south an average of 90
kilometers brown the internet renders
him eight types of dead well alright
then
yeah you should be shocked but I don't
imagine you're gonna be that upset
considering you almost broke my brain oh
jeez oh god what's happening this game
this game is much more delightful than I
ever could have imagined
I thought I was I thought it was gonna
be a ragdoll runners type horror show oh
my
well alright then that's it all right
Samuel story is done we're out here oh
okay
perfectly paranormal prevents man you oh
my god this game is actually gonna be
cool
Wow I can't believe I was putting this
off I was putting it off until I'd have
time enough to rage my brain out and the
pleasant surprises I'm gonna have a
great time with this game oh I can't
believe it
this is wondering you guys don't
understand how happy I am I was getting
ready to be so bad oh god yes
oh the chyron Express I get that that's
some reference to the underworld of some
type but either way
wait isn't char on a celestial body
probably named after some sort of old
God or demon or place in the underworld
of something like that
Oh joyous day Oh frabjous day
Callooh Callay new a bottle to the hood
result in such a terrible fate for Sam I
didn't but it's a boon to me be the only
thing that will meet Sam space today
there's also the ground in Hell oh jeez
you just had to be a dick didn't you we
have time to remember how to get up
herb Adair timber maybe if I slap the
ground a bit more it's gonna be a little
more beneficial to me well so why am I
in outer hell okay then well huh huh
Quinn what the huh are not no sir
does not like being dead Cyril bit well
so hates the eerie feeling of not having
any cash on him huh
he finds seven glowing notes in his
pocket
I can feel reasonably better okay
probably don't know well the horrible
sound he's hearing not the horrible
sound of the screaming Souls around him
the other horribly irritating son
okay I don't hear any screaming souls Oh
have a nice day thank you you're like
the guy from sort the court aren't you
you oh so are those bodies careening
pools of the sound is none other than
obliteration and oblivion extermination
and extinction the end decease and
demise the Grim Reaper is that a dog on
your oh it's hat he's trying to do a
kickflip on a skateboard in his dress
like a douche bag for someone's how in
his course horrifying voice he lays this
on said a fat rhyme yo yo yo oh boy you
must be Sam from the empowers provided
then he takes a second look at Sam and
his eye sockets ridin holy feces dude
your soul be like a diamond let me cut
you a deal that we can seal okay for
reals hide man it decided I didn't know
even notes in Sam's pocket or something
called a shred of life her every soul
has at least one and it is the biggest
unit in hell's currency followed by
quality of life a school of life sound
of life meaning of life and luck though
if you give me your shreds I'll
resurrect your face and get you out of
hell on one condition
you'll have to survive 24 hours with a
handicap I choose under my supervision
bro Sam decides to check out the rest of
Hell before doing any deals with
supernatural being okay I'll just be
skedaddling on my way don't mind me oh
hi boy hello there dear sir
let's see we can find a job fee you get
to be what summer
that'll be all your shreds dear sir all
right
that sounds fair yes Sam notices that
the souls that get into hell are forced
to get a job and become functioning
souls of society for most people this is
okay
a but for Sam it's
he hurls his shreds of death like he's
never Oh God
Oh God no wait hang on might think about
something here sweepa that will be all
your shreds sir could be worse sir
whatever I don't understand the concept
of punishment here what's over here if
we can find huh
you get to be a struggling freelance
artist Oh God no he'll be all your
shreds dear sir ah also why was the
meaning of life a single sperm a lunch
dear sirs and Madam's take all your
concern related concerns up with upper
management
see you in five hours oh all right then
bye I thought I was gonna get
interesting story he goes back to death
and his deal okay
habitat hashes oh I'm starting to like
this I was already predisposed to hate
this game but never lost read the next
time he meets the gatekeeper of Hell way
whenever that's going to be how do I
know I'm gonna need that I broke I only
get to do these deals and does the
concept of a year apply down here live
in biz you have to do it manually
reserving them I will stop speaking in
okay so it was just one shred of life
and got me back up in the living
situation I guess I actually really like
this guy who just traveled through time
space and logic finds himself fully
alive and more importantly rich again
his joy is only dimmed by the fact that
he can't move at all guys is when he
shows up dead oh jeez oh yo yo bro yeah
you be okay no can you hear me
I Britt I don't know how to breathe
apparently yes uh I'll try to blink
you'll be a little bit about a bit about
a thing be fine no I so this here be the
dealing [ __ ] Oh your body functions be
manual oh geez gonna have to do stuff on
[ __ ] um you'll be turning kind of blue
might want to consider breathing oh jeez
oh jeez yes yes [ __ ] in you be blinking
and breathing happy picture
all right go survive for a day and I'll
let you live normally for the rest of
your life I mean all somehow die within
the next 24 hours you'll go to hell and
I'll keep your stress rap oh geez
they're doing kick flips if in your knee
oh thanks death you're so cool Sam has
to make an effort to get up this time he
has to focus on his spine jeez oh jeez
and once again he has to remind himself
how to walk oh by the way dude you be
getting late for work Oh Sam does
something that resembles walking
bathroom gonna do a kickflip now all
right your kicks I didn't pass out from
the box
kept it going to be a long day oh yeah
let's see oh boy now I can see maybe I
spoke too soon about enjoy stepping with
the same leg geez
uh-huh I'm having a great time oh geez
oh boy
oh god oh boy with that's not the
bathroom is it geez Sam has some truffle
moisture and has to focus on his spine
she's he has to use his opposite leg to
get up again
Oh hard is it to blink Sam I don't know
man come on lay off I'm God alright you
keep trying
I'm Sam has some trouble Oh
Oh God
ah you're impressing no one's okay I'm
gonna make it I'm gonna make it to
pencil he I know shut up narrator I'm
really trying here
god I just can't catch my breath some
trouble with his paw Oh has to focus on
his high Sam's ass is out from the lack
of oxygen do i I'm really trying here
it's hard to breathe apparently okay now
we got it
yep blink blink breathe step step turn
breathe breathe RM holds on to that
toothbrush like his life depends on it
oh Jesus ha
uh I did in with his mouth alright then
he lets go house yeah blink blink blink
blink ok god this is gonna be so
difficult grab brush brush brush brush
brush fry fry fry fry fry fresh refresh
spit breathe spit goals Wow Otto's pick
some rush rush rush rush rush rush rush
rush rush spit breathe breathe breathe
blink blink blink blink breathe breathe
rush rush rush rush rush rush rush rush
rush rush rush rush rush rush with
screen down god damn em is ready to
smile hello for at least yeah ok I could
just lay on the floor I could just lay
on the forms out from the lack of oxygen
pool I was in the middle of the
breathing thing
ok if I hold in my breath apparently
that works just a little bit goddamn it
hey yep ok Europe ok I got a full breath
lip now da ba ba haba haba haba haba
haba haba haba haba haba haba goddammit
if I just keep my mouth open and just
suck air eternally inside my body
nothing can stop me Sam can't leave
before taking a leak and taking a shower
really
okay damn it dupa dupa dupa tah
don't mind my zombie like trance tip ow
my spine broke the wrong way too much
momentum that was probably my problem
I'm a bit dirty from experiencing all
that hell had to offer me Adam tries to
take a leak I don't know how I'm gonna
be able to oh god okay heard hey dude
have you seen Matt oh geez
don't mind me don't mind me don't mind
me death it's okay
do I still need to breathe I probably
still need to breathe I mean I'm
assuming my parents will forgive me if I
get piss all over the place also do they
come in here and clean so they wouldn't
even be worried about it ah god damn it
my spine some peas perfectly yeah me I'm
a perfect peer not a perfect Walker just
yet but peeing
that's my mainstay yeah let me just grab
this Sam tries to take a shower
yep let me just just kind of do a little
looks like a mantis that's trying to
explain to someone how a bicycle work
here their daddy their dad today I'm so
clean gasps blink blink blink
I should probably close my eyes for this
shouldn't I gross is gonna burn yeah
there we go
I'm smart look at how smart I am
whoo Hey Oh multitasking and keeping my
eyes fresh and clean nothing what else
do I need to do clean my hands ah look
at me go clean as a whistle hey good job
Sam oh look at me I'm god damn it Hammer
hammer Hammer hammer Hammer hammer his
wait till my spine breaks oh there we go
okay Dale here breathe breathe
oh [ __ ] dirt clean and empty Sam decides
to find some clues uh-huh where would
those be mmm [ __ ] here Sam can open
doors now oh nice livable so smart Miam
Miam do what is over there Sam
no maybe clothes don't mind me let me
let me live my life damn it
okay what's over here oh nice art of me
I'm so beautiful it's a good thing I
take care of this incredible bow Sam
enters his wardrobe
Burt what will you wear today I didn't
know I don't know what kind of clothes I
have
uh what's in your anything of it'd be
all no no nobody wants to look at Sam's
skinny legs any longer than they have to
so Sam puts on his pants first that
sounds stupid who would even do that
who'd wear pants in the first place that
sounds dumb he picks a pair of blue
jeans the ugly ones hey a one leg at a
time am i right her blink blink like Sam
successfully puts on his pants feeling
more accomplished than ever he proceeds
to find a jacket only the best one will
do okay what about an undershirt first
you might want to be worried about that
cool okay how about you goofy I almost
had that let me just get there we go
left
rip rip holy game is ready for the day
pa he's not okay where are my shoes
anybody found any shoes over here Q's is
how okay can I put them all third
there's there there's he puts on his
shoe nice living the dream of having
shoes on thanks for having so much
confidence and a lot of sarcasm for me
announcer boo do I get to carry on with
my life now her near declared it dad it
dared it saw stairs down the stairs with
great sound soccer girl himself down the
stairs use to hurling money around Oh
oopsies boop doop oopsies how's my bad
okay here we go Kirpal herp a derp derp
derp don't man Samuel he's manual yeah
YP rooster is Sam's favorite Gabe he has
no time for playing with a flappy
rooster right now though how about [ __ ]
you I'm gonna play can i you
hey hey not daddy work well oh that was
either supposed to or not supposed to
happen we'll never know okay gotta go
now hey Dad are you doing the story at
this time and gang wars are still an
escalating problem at Bridge Street
where the police are struggling to
regain control commuters are advised to
oh hey dude still alive huh yep that's
me ow
don't ignore that I'll be on my way now
goodbye gotta go out my front door and
live my life you know as anyone would
this house is big there is a note saying
sent over a maid to make you breakfast
don't breathe in while chewing Oh God
all right then thanks mom
herb gosh [ __ ] laughs [ __ ] well shitty
tits that didn't work at all okay blink
blink blink breathe breathe pick up it's
his left bumper but goddamn it yeah
disgusting right okay harp
num num num num num num num num this is
delicious apparently oh [ __ ] okay at
this rep Sam spills most of the food on
the floor no one is surprised Hey okay
breathe breathe okay do I need eight
anymore
bling bling bling bling bling num num
num num num num num num hey much more do
I need eat nothing there's nothing left
never mind I guess I'm good I'm ready
I'm ready I'm ready I'm ready you think
the maid would have cleaned up a bit hey
Sam decides to try his luck on some
coffee drinking Sam so far so hot he
blows on it before taking a sip
ah Jesus
oh that was my bad ha ha ooh uh-huh
with some color in his system Sam finds
it easier to exist yay
ah [ __ ] me I did it finally makes it
yeah door beaten terrified al cubed yep
that sounds like me
her predictor I am totally gonna kick
flip over York oh god there's the game
machine bye oh jeez where's it going oh
geez I gotta keep up with that where's
it going are you going where you going
machine machine like that when I got it
oh dude my car goodbye it be loose why
do you have to drive with me okay all
right then so anyway I am out of time
but this game was an incredibly pleasant
surprise I am going to wait for the rest
to decide if I actually want to do more
episodes of this but this game is really
funny and really fun to play so I might
play more of it so thank you everybody
so much for watching let me know what
you thought down in the comments below
and as always I'll see you in the next
video bye-bye
[Music]